meine damen und herren wir haben heute
im präsidium und dem bundesvorstand der
cdu intensiv über die wahlergebnisse von
gestern und über das weitere vorgehen
gesprochen
es steht völlig außer frage dieses
ergebnis kann darauf und wird die union
nicht zufrieden stellen wir haben zwar
im schlussspurt eine aufholjagd
geschafft und rot-rot-grün verhindert
aber
zugleich gibt es schmerzliche verluste
es hat nicht gereicht für platz eins das
war unser anspruch das war unsere
ambition und mein glückwunsch geht an
die
mitbewerbenden parteien die zugelegt
haben bei dieser wahl ein ergebnis unter
30 prozent ist nicht der anspruch der
union als volkspartei
besonders drastisch sind die verluste in
ostdeutschland ausgefallen die gründe
für dieses wahlergebnis sind
vielschichtig auch das ist heute in den
wortmeldungen der vielen vielen
kolleginnen und kollegen des
bundesvorstands deutlich geworden und
natürlich weiß ich auch dass ich meinen
persönlichen anteil an diesem
wahlergebnis habe wir haben besprochen
dass wir das alles intensiv aufarbeiten
das werden wir tun in einem
strukturierten prozess mit den
landesverbänden mit den kreisverbänden
und mit anderen an der basis der
generalsekretär wird dazu gleich noch
etwas sagen
und das werden wir tun
ganz gleich ob wir am ende dieses
prozesses in regierungsverantwortung
sind oder in der opposition auch in
regierungsverantwortung
muss eine erneuerung der union
stattfinden auf allen ebenen und das ist
das was wir dann gemeinsam besprechen
werde
das ist die verantwortung die wir
gegenüber unserer partei haben aber es
gibt auch eine verantwortung für unsere
wählerinnen und wähler eine
verantwortung für unser land die
wählerinnen und wähler die cdu und csu
wählt haben wollen dass wir auch
verantwortung übernehmen und regieren
und wir sind der überzeugung dass eine
führung eine regierung unter führung der
union das beste ist für unser land und
auch diesen wählern fühlen wir uns
verpflichtet
und deshalb haben wir gestern unsere
bereitschaft dazu erklärt das ergebnis
der bundestagswahl stellt nämlich nicht
nur die union sondern auch deutschland
vor große herausforderungen
bei fast jeder bundestagswahl war am
ende klar eine partei hat einen klaren
regierungsauftrag hat eine mehrheit die
muss regieren und die andere hat die
oppositionsrolle zugewiesen bekommen für
uns können wir sagen keine partei kann
aus diesem klaren ergebnis für sich
einen regierungsauftrag ableiten auch
wir nicht auch das habe ich gestern
deutlich gemacht
auch die spd nicht es ist ein moment wo
gerade die beiden großen volksparteien
die den anspruch haben müssen um die 30
prozent zu liegen mit demut vor den
wähler treten müssen und sagen müssen
nein diese großen volksparteien die über
30 prozent bei früheren wahlen immer
gehabt haben haben diesmal dieses ziel
nicht erreicht die einen bei 24 und die
anderen 25
und deshalb ist jetzt der wahlkampf
vorbei keiner sollte so auftreten als
wenn er alleine entscheiden könnte wie
er eine regierung bildet und deshalb
sind gespräche mit möglichen partnern
jetzt erforderlich wir müssen uns da auf
augenhöhe begegnen wir müssen auch
gegensätze überwinden zwischen
unterschiedlichen politischen strömungen
eine nächste bundesregierung wird ja
aller voraussicht nach drei große partei
familien miteinander verbinden müssen
und das hat es in dieser form nach einer
bundestagswahl in deutschland bisher
auch nicht gegeben klar ist kanzler wird
in deutschland der der eine mehrheit im
deutschen bundestag
hinter sich bringt so ist unsere
verfassung so ist unsere staatspraxis
seit gründung unseres landes und kanzler
kann auch nur der werden dem es gelingt
gegensätze zu verbinden und ein gutes
gemeinsames projekt für die nächsten
vier jahre zu entwickeln
der bundesvorstand das präsidium der cdu
ist sich darin einig dass wir zu
gesprächen für eine sogenannte jamaika
koalition bereit stehen und meine praxis
als regierungschef jetzt war es immer
dass sich jeder partner auch
wiederfinden muss in einer solchen
koalition dass jeder auf sein profil
entwickeln muss das nicht alles nur auf
die person des regierungschefs
zugeschnitten sein darf sondern dass
jeder partner mit seinen themen auch
vorkommen muss eine koalition
ist keine zwangsehe und ist auch keine
arithmetik wo man einfach addiert wie
viel passt denn zusammen und am ende
sind das über 50 prozent sondern eine
koalition muss ein politisches projekt
sein wo auch das ist ein gegensatz zur
großen koalition jetzt alle den willen
haben und auch die lust haben etwas
positives für das land zu gestalten und
nicht ständig den eindruck vermitteln
dass man eigentlich gar nicht regieren
will und dass das eigentlich alles
freudlos ist deshalb glaube ich dass wir
zu einer gesellschaftlichen breite und
einem jamaika-bündnis beitragen könnten
dafür sind zwei schlüsselbegriffe
prägend das eine ist zukunfts koalition
und das andere ist nachhaltigkeit
deutschland muss modernisiert werden
deutschland braucht eine koalition für
mehr nachhaltigkeit und das in jeder
hinsicht
nachhaltigkeit heißt klimaschutz
nachhaltigkeit heißt aber auch
nachhaltige finanzpolitik eine
finanzpolitik zu lasten künftiger
generationen
auch das muss eine künftige koalition
prägen wir brauchen mehr tempo bei der
digitalisierung der planungen wir wissen
alle dass das alles viel zu langsam geht
und eine neue koalition muss sich dieses
ziel setzen und wir brauchen auch das
wichtige anliegen dass wir zu
wirtschaftlichem wachstum wieder
zurückkommen das ist ein besonderes
anliegen der fdp das wir teilen den
grünen teilen wir das engagement für den
klimaschutz und die umwandlung unseres
industrieland zu einem klimaneutralen
industrieland zum weiteren vorgehen wir
sind im gespräch wir werden die
gespräche sicher auch noch formalisiert
in den nächsten tagen fortsetzen aber
hier ist mir wichtig das darf nicht das
klein klein sein dass wir aus früheren
sondierungen kennen
vier wochen lang sondieren mit
verhandlungen über jeden kleinen komma
strich
mit vielen eckigen klammern was alles
nicht gelöst ist und am ende dann eine
gescheiterte sondierung kann nicht das
verfahren dieses mal sein wir brauchen
gespräche aus denen deutlich werden muss
trauen sich die jeweiligen partner das
zu das gemeinsam so das war armin
laschet wir haben uns notizen gemacht
werden gleich darüber sprechen aber wir
gehen gleich weiter zu anna lena hat
bernburg zu den grünen die sich auch für
die pressestelle auf
mehreren kanälen live übertragen wird
nochmal kurz der hinweis die
bundespressekonferenz ist keine
institution der bundesregierung sondern
ein unabhängiger verein von
journalistinnen und journalisten die aus
berlin über die bundespolitik berichten
und unsere aufgabe ist dass
pressekonferenzen zu veranstalten damit
unsere mitgliedschaft umfassen sich
umfassend informieren kann das als
vorbemerkung und jetzt hat das wort
problem burg
da schon montag auch von unserer seite
jetzt wo das vorläufige endergebnis
vorliegt freuen wir uns dass wir 16
direktmandate
gewonnen haben was gestern abend noch
nicht so klar war klar es jetzt auch
dass die spd stärkste kraft ist
herzlichen glückwunsch von uns an dieser
stelle an die sozialdemokraten wir haben
einen klaren auftrag von den wählerinnen
und wählern bekommen für einen aufbruch
in unserem land zu sorgen auch wenn das
ergebnis deutlich hinter dem zurück
liegt was wir erwartet und für was wir
gekämpft haben jetzt eine erneuerung
dieses landes kann zu gehen und deutlich
zu machen dass wir nicht nur
schrittweise voran kommen müssen sondern
dass wir wirklich eine erneuerung
brauchen in der infrastruktur in der
digitalisierung unseres landes und dass
die klimapolitik querschnitts politik
einer nächsten bundesregierung sein muss
das bedeutet nicht nur im umweltressort
verankert sondern sich durch zieht durch
die wirtschafts- und industriepolitik
die verkehrspolitik die
landwirtschaftspolitik weil die frage
der klimaneutralität die zukunftsaufgabe
unserer gesellschaft und damit auch die
zukunft für den wohlstand in unserem
land ist auf dieser grundlage werden wir
jetzt gemeinsam robert habeck und ich
als parteivorsitzende gespräche mit den
anderen parteien führen haben wir
gestern abend ja auch schon mal deutlich
gemacht dass das so ist dass wir vor
allem vielen geschützten raum auch mit
kleineren parteien gespräche führen
werden um diesen auftrag den die
wählerinnen und wähler uns gegeben haben
für eine echte erneuerung jetzt in
deutschland zu sorgen gestärkt in die
nächsten wochen zu gehen
haben
mit dem wahlabend durch tatsächlich eine
neue zeitrechnung in deutschland an wenn
es nicht und ich glaube dann werden an
der leute wirklich kirche werden nochmal
eine neuauflage einer sogenannten
frühjahr genannten großen koalition
geben soll wird es einen 3
parteienbündnis geben das ist auf der
bundesebene nicht üben man muss
vielleicht auch sagen im wahlkampf nicht
wirklich vorbereitet worden der
wahlkampf hat er seine eigenen logik
turbulenzen irgend und wirrungen
aber dass aus dem wahlkampf voraus ein
klares mandat und eine klare richtung
für energie ausgegeben würde das kann
man glaube ich nicht behaupten
gleichwohl muss natürlich wie immer die
regierung genau sieht sie mit einer
klaren politischen vorstellung einer
politischen identität mit einem
politischen plan sofort ans werk gehen
dafür sind die herausforderung einfach
zu groß und zu dominant als dass es dann
eine politik des kleinsten gemeinsamen
nenners des ewigen kompromisses des
[Musik]
suchens nach unten immer nur geben kann
das ist natürlich vor allem angesichts
der globalen erderwärmung und der
schlechten bilanz deutschlands co2
emissionen einzusparen die
vordringlichste aufgabe da im
klimaschutz fortschritte zu erzielen
aber auch demographie und rente sind
wichtige themen die liegen geblieben
sind europa einwanderung
fachkräftemangel und flucht denn ein
system zu bringen die außenpolitik
gerade nach dem debakel in afghanistan
neu zu durchdenken neu zu reichen europa
nach zögerlichen und nur in der kroner
pandemie gegangenen schritten wieder auf
einen kurs der integration zu bringen
und das kann eigentlich immer nur
passieren wenn deutschland im zusammen
mit frankreich entschieden die schritte
geht den zusatz sozialen zusammenhalt
hochzuhalten in zeiten der zumutungen
die ohne frage die ökologische
transformation auch bereit hält dafür zu
sorgen dass die gesellschaft nicht
auseinanderfällt das sind dringliche
aufgaben das setzt voraus dass die
kommenden regierungsparteien sich der
größe der aufgaben klar werden wir haben
vor dem wahlkampf und auch während des
wahlkampfs uns auf diese zeit
vorbereitet und unabhängig von dem
wahlergebnis ergibt sich eine
notwendigkeit einfach aus den
verhältnissen dass wir unseren beitrag
leisten und ich würde sagen stark und
vielleicht auch vor allem wir unseren
beitrag leisten dass diese regierung aus
dem gebirge der letzten wochen und
monate heraus zu einem zu einer
regierung für das land und für den
menschen wird die das vertrauen das dann
mit den ballack sicher
materialisiert hat auch würdig ist und
das ist eine anspruchsvolle aufgabe und
auf die konzentrieren wir uns jetzt mit
voller kraft
herzlichen dank dann kommen wir zu
fragen die erste hatte krämer
die zwei fahren wir nicht
ständig darüber beraten haben
hört sich schlägt also das war robert
habeck hat deutlich länger gesprochen
und auch substanzieller als anna-lena
berbalk aber ich würde vorschlagen dass
wir der reihe nach mal vorgehen wir
haben vorhin gehört und ich finde
ehrlich gesagt fand ist unverschämt aber
was er gesagt hat dass er sagt dass
keine partei aus diesem ergebnis einen
regierungsauftrag
ableiten kann sehe ich überhaupt nicht
so der hat sich dann in typischer
laschet man ihr dann auch noch wieder
versprochen und zwar hat er gesagt keine
partei kann aus diesem klaren ergebnis
und hat sich da also selbst freut sich
widersprochen einen regierungsauftrag
ableiten wir nicht und auch die spd
nicht gut also wahrscheinlich hatte sich
auch bei keine versprochen denn eine
partei kann es natürlich dass die spd
die hat nämlich gewonnen natürlich kann
olaf scholz aus diesem ergebnis einen
auftrag ableiten dass er eine regierung
bilden soll
armin laschet hat sozusagen rum wie ein
angeschlagener
kämpfer das ist so er ist ja sozusagen
in den zwölf runden dieses wahlkampfes
jetzt in die zwölfte runde eingebogen
und taumelt eben und ein taumelnder man
kann sehr sehr schlecht die zukunft für
deutschland vorbereiten und das ist aus
meiner sicht deutlich geworden das hat
kein wert kein plan irgendwie also wie
sondern er ist eine art positioniert
sich sozusagen als eine art manager des
nachbarn da hat mir habe ich schon
gleich viel besser gefallen er hat
sozusagen gesagt wir müssen das dass das
und das angehen und das sind grüne
kernthemen und
unausgesprochen hat er klar gemacht wer
die mit uns nicht mitgehen will mit dem
können wir auch nicht koalieren also wir
sehen starke grüne wir sehen heute an
diesem tag eine starke fdp wir sehen
einen olaf scholz der vor kraft nicht
gehen kann und wir sehen einen
angeschlagenen cdu chef der für seine
schlechten verlierer finde ich auch
einen schlechten verlierer klaus er hat
nämlich stadt zumindest auch mal zu
anzuerkennen sozusagen herzlichen
glückwunsch sowie annalena baerbock das
gemacht hat sagt er man muss auch zeigen
dass man lust hat zu regieren und nicht
das alles freudlos ist also gemünzt auf
scholz ja aber das ist ja irgendwie in
sich
maximal ironisch denn
armin laschet wirkt der jetzt auch nicht
gerade wie also dass freundin paket der
sich richtig darauf freut chef einer
jamaika koalition zu sein sondern es
geht jetzt halt ein anderes managen des
machbaren und was ich bei annalena
baerbock die du erwähnst interessant
fand der teuren schönen kleinen gruß für
christian lindner dabei wenn ich nicht
verhört habe klein den zieht nämlich
gesagt wenn wir sprechen jetzt mit den
kleineren parteien also jetzt in science
selbst
sie werden also von einer kleinen partei
zu sprechen ist auch noch gut wie viel
hat sich vor drei prozent daraus kann
man christian lindner schon zum zweck
erklären es wird ihm aber quasi nicht
gefallen haben das waren 3 punkt
entschuldigen bei diesem zitat waren
drei punkte dabei also gemeinsam mit
robert habeck sie ist da noch nicht raus
gespräche auch mit den kleineren
parteien also der fdp die auf dem
dritten platz ist und in einem
geschützten raum also das was wir vorher
ja auch gestern schon berichtet haben da
gibt's erstmal die internen gespräche
denn natürlich haben die einen hebel und
können natürlich der spd unbedingt die
ampel will einiges abfall dann weiß ich
mir was ich mir vorgestellt habe wie
schaut jemand diese pressekonferenz der
nicht wie wir sich 24 stunden mit
politik ausgesetzt und wenn der sich
anschaut was armin laschet da gerade
erzählt hat dann hat er das gefühl nach
gestern erlebt in einer anderen realität
als armin laschet denn sich als
zweitplatzierter dorthin zu sitzen und
mehr oder weniger schon eine
vorsortierung zu definieren er hat dann
ja die themen angesprochen die sozusagen
klimaschutz dann technologie er hat
sozusagen die grünen und die fdp beide
bereits angesprochen so als hätte jetzt
hier eine offizielle erklärung zu
verlautbaren und übermorgen treffen wir
uns dann in raum xy da fragt sich doch
jeder normale mensch wo liegt der
eigentlich warum lässt er nicht wie man
das denken würde nach einer
bundestagswahl wo es an erstplatzierten
und ein zweitplatzierten warum sagt er
nicht ja ich hab's nicht auf platz eins
geschafft also hat olaf scholz jetzt
erst mal das wort und der soll versuchen
das hinzubekommen was er sich vorstellt
wenn er es nicht hinbekommt und ich kann
man ja sagen als armin laschet ich gehe
davon aus dass das scheitern wird warum
auch immer dann bin ich dran also ganz
klar platz 1 oder scholz platz zwei
armin laschet und das was er da verzapft
hat was er da gerade gesagt hat das
versteht kein mensch armin laschet im
größtes argument wird wahrscheinlich
sein es sind doch nur 1,6 prozent
aber es sind eben doch ein bein und
wänden stunden seine millionen stimmen
und pauls hinweis weist er den weg so zu
sagen genau so muss es beginnen und da
wo paul die klammer aufgemacht hat und
das wird scheitern die ampel die scholz
sich vornimmt aus welchem grund auch
immer da haben die wähler und die
unterstützung der cdu das recht zu
erfahren woran ist entscheiden könnte
aus sicht der union und dann würde schuh
draus war und ist jedoch alles sondern
geheimgesprächen ich habe mit christian
lindner telefoniert und sagt heute abend
zusammen da sagt er wieder acht ich kann
ja mit dem christian mit dem hab ich
schon mal eine koalition gemacht und
jetzt sie stehen auch wieder rüber
machen wir im bund genauso und mit
annalena baerbock rede ich auch noch so
also was soll denn das ich meine wir
haben die bundestagswahl hinter sich die
sollen klar sagen was sie wollen und
klarmachen wer auf platz eins und platz
zwei und eins ist mir noch bei habig
aufgefallen da ist ein neues
horrorszenario benannt worden nämlich
der kleinste gemeinsame nenner einer
solchen koalition von der er auch war
von dem nenner er auch warnt aber man
muss sich mal vorstellen worum es da
geht da liegen die punkte so weit
auseinander ja das muss vereinbart also
angenommen thomas wir beide wollen
miteinander eine neue zeitungen
rausgeben ja und ich will wild
fernsehsender wir gleich bei der zeitung
wir wollen dennoch her und vielleicht
dass wir wollen eine neue zeitung
herausgeben und ich will kurze texte
große bunte bilder und große
überschriften und du möchtest lange
texte jetzt und willi überschriften und
wir machen jetzt eine koalition wisst
ihr was da rauskommt ein unleserlicher
kraut und rüben blatt und diese
koalition scheint schon wieder sozusagen
in der gefahr zu stehen kompromisse zu
machen
ende kein gefallen und da fällt mir was
ein vielleicht geht ja auch in einem
dreierbündnis das österreichische modell
also sie vereinbaren die ressorts a b
und c sind unions ressort d und e sind
grün und f und g sind gelb und in diesen
ressorts kann jeder seine
wahlversprechen
einlösen und die anderen halten den
nagel was wäre eine möglichkeit die ich
glauben würde wenn das irgendwie kommt
nehmen die deutsche kompromiss maschine
kommt wird das furchtbar wie die
zuweisungen aus herumführen du wirst sie
nochmals zu psychologisieren was die
grünen da gedacht haben vielleicht
interpretiert auch zu viel rein aber sie
haben ihre pressekonferenz begonnen
während armin laschet noch gesprochen
hat also sie hatten nicht mal die chance
sich bis zum ende anzuschauen war es
armin laschet denn vielleicht von ihnen
will für mich auch ein symbolisches
zeichen der grünen der auch selber schon
sagt er möchte gerne gespräche auf
augenhöhe führen
[Musik]